[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody it's Charlie so Todd
Phillips dropped this teaser for Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker in full makeup showing
the transition so I think it's easy to
see once you watch this why they wanted
Joaquin Phoenix for this character like
he just does a really awesome version of
crazy and that's what you need for the
Joker you need somebody that can show
that descent into madness so we got to
break this down and compare him to the
other versions of the Joker I'll be sure
to include my rankings of new Joker's
after watching this during the video I'm
still doing the giveaway for that DC
streaming service all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so a lot of
people when I drop that other video
notice that there's actually an Easter
Egg for Batman Arkham games the
amusement Mile is actually a location
that shows up in Gotham in the Arkham
series this is sort of base of
operations for the Joker it's not where
his origin happened but it is a location
that's just important for his character
it seems like this version of the
character might get his origin here
though just because it's near the haha
comedy club like Oh everybody's thinking
about Killing Joke and it's near this
scene where he encounters this street
clown for the first time and starts
messing with his nose so like a lot of
people notice the most striking thing
about his Joker makeup it does look very
grounded in real world but he has a red
nose and there hasn't really been a
version of the Joker either in the
comics or in movies TV shows or video
games that has worn a red nose so if
you're not a Batman historian like most
big Batman fans are bill fingers
original inspiration for the Joker
character was a couple of movies in a
very specific location at Coney Island
where he used to go hang out and just
have fun
there was a 1928 movie called the man
who laughs which you know usually when
they talk about the Joker they show his
picture so even if you haven't seen that
movie you're probably familiar with this
take the
other part came from this riot at Coney
Island where Bill Finger used to go to
have fun this is horrifying clown mascot
the inspiration for his Batman redesign
of Bob Kane's character the original
Batman came from this 1926 movie called
the bat the rumor is is that his name is
Arthur Fleck before he becomes the Joker
and he's come back to Gotham to care for
his mother when he finds himself at this
comedy club and is inspired and
obviously descends into this crazy
madness and becomes the Joker character
there was a clip from Batman of the
animated series that shows the Joker's
origin inside a comedy club but it's not
going to be quite exactly like that it
was the origin of the Mark Hamill
version of the Joker that they did for
the TV series Red Nose aside this is
probably the most real world grounded
version of the Joker that we've seen
since Heath Ledger's take because
Christopher Nolan's whole deal was it
was going to be a grounded take on the
character like what would happen if
there was a Batman in real life if a
billionaire decided to put on a suit and
go fight crime
so naturally his Joker was also a very
grounded take on the Joker but it seems
like this version of Arthur Arthur Fleck
whatever his name is going to be is
inspired by these Street clowns in
amusement mile part of the beauty of
Heath Ledger's version of the character
is that he always tells a different
version of his origin story within the
context of the story you know what his
mission is you know why he's doing what
he's doing in present day but you don't
really know much about him before he
took that persona what's different about
this version of the character is is that
you're actually going to see that
descent into madness so whether or not
you think that that's an important thing
seeing why the Joker became the Joker
that is what they're doing but it seems
like while he's at this hahas comedy
club in amusement Mile he slowly comes
to some grand cosmic realization and
then sees these Street clowns just has
some sort of epiphany in his head it
starts to break down like in the teaser
footage that I posted the other day he's
antagonizing one of these Street clowns
pulling the nose off of its face so I'll
link that video at the end of this but
that could be coming while he's slowly
descending into madness like you start
to see the clown's and that gives him
the idea to wear the clown makeup the
thing about the Heath Ledger Joker
though is is that the way he did his
makeup was still very true to the comic
book versions of the Joker so this is a
like departure from that but you could
view it is just a proto of what Heath
Ledger was doing like by the events of
Dark Knight Heath Ledger's Joker had
been the character for a while so he had
refined his look so to speak although it
did seem kind of slapdash though he
wasn't sitting in a makeup chair for six
hours every morning before he went out
to commit crimes so think of Joaquin
Phoenix's character as like the very
first origins of se Heath Ledger's Joker
so maybe you know if this character goes
on 10 20 years down the road he starts
to refine the way he wears the makeup
the red nose is a little bit weird but I
am kind of digging how raw it is like it
definitely makes him look like he's gone
completely mad in a lot of the other
versions of the Joker that we've seen in
the movies and TV shows are a little
more organized even though they swing
true chaotic in their alignment his
performance looks spot-on Heath Ledger
still probably my favorite Joker but his
was inspired by The Killing Joke in
Arkham series house on a serious earth
with a little bit of Tom Waits for the
vocal mannerisms in his way of speaking
there's this clip from the 1970s of Tom
Waits doing an interview that sounds
spot-on
like what Heath Ledger did with the
Joker's vocal performance I got here
last night I was on the plane from Paris
for about 22 hours mm-hmm it was a
fascinating flight you remind me of my
father isn't that totally creepy that
sounds exactly like what Heath Ledger
talked like as the Joker so neither todd
phillips nor joaquin phoenix have stated
publicly who his joker is most inspired
by but during an interview that he did
about four years ago when he was still
in talks with marvel about becoming dr.
strange he talked about his favorite
comic books and specifically calls out
Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns in
the same Arkham Asylum serious house on
Sirius earth series that inspired Heath
Ledger's take on the Joker so he is a
comic book fan and he does seem like he
understands the characters but after
seeing this clip of Joaquin Phoenix
here's my list of top Joker's in the
movies TV shows and video games of
course but because there's about 24
total I'm just gonna limit this to my
top 5 so starting with 5 working
my way up to number one number five
jared leto maybe he'll be able to do
something more definitive with the
character if they end up doing that
Harley Quinn vs. the Joker movie number
four Jack Nicholson he was actually my
first Joker because I saw him before I
started watching reruns of classic Cesar
Romero
I also saw Batman 1989 before I saw
Batman the Animated Series 3 Zach
Galifianakis in Lego Batman another
actor that I'd never thought about when
I thought about Batman or the Joker but
he does a really compelling crazy and
his vocal performance was great not Mark
Hamill great but it was still very very
good within the context and the tone of
what Lego Batman was trying to be
obviously that's more of a comedy film
than like a straight-up action Batman
film number 2 Cesar Romero one of the
classics the original Batman 1960s TV
series I only found him because of
reruns obviously I'm not a super old
person so I wouldn't have watched the
series when it first ran but tied for
number one you probably guessed this
already or Mark Hamill and Heath Ledger
you know because Heath Ledger has such a
compelling take on the character and
live-action but I still think that Mark
Hamill's Joker is one of the most
definitive versions of the character he
just happens to be animated it's just
like Kevin Conroy Batman is one of the
best bat men of all time he just happens
to be animated but speaking of Batman
online obviously we're all expecting a
new version of the character to debut
during Matt Reeves Batman film and
there's a rumored full-blown Batman in a
bat suit during titans season 1
congratulations to kuro-chan ok you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my youtube channel so I can get your
details click here for that other teaser
of Joaquin Phoenix Joker and click here
for that new Avengers 4 titled teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]